hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round four of this
year's superbit chess classic uh it is
Fabiano Corona versus Yani promise and I
I thought as soon as I saw this matchup
that this will be extremely exciting to
watch because Fabiano has been
commenting on the entire world Chase
championship match between England and
Indiana so it will be very interesting
to see what opening choice will he go
for against Jian he's uh you know he's
seen what what young plays against ding
in the world's championship match so he
doesn't know everything that he has
prepared and to what extent but he of
course has some ideas he's a you know a
top player himself he's a former Watcher
Championship Challenger himself uh he
has the white pieces uh you know he he's
a former 2800 uh let's see let's see
what he
um uh prepared for this one and it's
also a very important to note that uh
Fabi has never defeated nepo in
classical chess they've played together
like 13 games the 12 games were drawn
and nepo defeated Fabian one game and
even in Rapid chess Jan has a much
better score against Fabi 19 wins the
eight with a 36 draw so it would go a
long way for fabita actually beat nepo
in classical so let's see what happened
Fabi opens with Ponte D4 we have Knight
to F6 Ponte D5 uh sorry uh Knight to F3
first uh Ponte D5 Ponte C4 and E6 we
have the Queen's Gambit declined Knights
the C3 and C5 and nipple goes for the uh
three nights variation of the semi
tarash and now see capture sund5 is the
most uh common move here but here we
have E3 Knight to C6 and now C captures
on D5 e captures and Bishop to B5 so
this is all very standard stuff here C
captures on D4 Knight captures Bishop to
D7 uh getting rid of the pin and now
castles with Bishop to D6 and now Knight
back to F3 not allowing any unnecessary
trades and just keeping the tension we
have Bishop to E6 uh adding a Defender
to the pawn here and uh now just Pawn to
B3 preparing defianchetto the dark
Square bishop and there is a game where
castles was played and it's a very top
tier game Magnus Carlsen defeated
um uh uh pregnant just castled here it
was last year in the uh Oslo Esports cup
the Magnus won a very nice game but here
we have pawned the A6 and it is now as
of move at 11 that we already have a
completely new game so okay Bishop is
attacked Bishop goes back we have Knight
to E5 now 4 forcing further trades as
fabi's Bishop uh is is kind of very
nicely placed on this diagonal so Knight
captures an E5 with Bishop characters
and just Bishop to B2 so defending the
Knight here and apple brings The Rook
into the game which Tempo the the Knight
is now attacked twice and Rook the C1
and Nepal just castles here and it
doesn't seem like Fabi got all that much
out of the opening seems like nepo
equalized pretty much um without any any
troubles he does have the isolated the
d-pawn but you know it's uh the the
isolated Pawn is only a weakness if you
don't know how to how to use it to your
advantage otherwise it could also just
be an advantage so Pawn to F4 by Fabi
and the bishop back to C7 also Bishop to
B8 can be played but uh Nepal wants to
re-maneuver the bishop over to B6 so
Knight to E2 we have Bishop to B6 and
now uh D3 Pawn could be very weak so
Bishop to D4 Bishop captures on D4 and
not Knight capture Sandy for putting
pressure on the bishop on E6 but just
Queen to A5 putting pressure on the A2
Pawn so Queen to 80 defending uh also by
playing Queen day two you you connect
your Rooks Here and Now Rook F the E8
uh you're gonna move the bishop and then
the E3 Pawn might again become a problem
we have Pawn to H3 now stopping any G4
action from nepo and Bishop back to D7
we have Rook captures on C8 uh Rook
captures and now Queen to B2 uh now that
the Rook move you also don't want your
queen uh behind the pawn here and you
might have some ideas of Bishop to F5 if
you can trade bishops get the Knight F5
the G7 Pawn could become very weak uh
the queen is uh quite beautiful on this
diagonal so nepo just takes care of that
he plays a queen to C5 now even if you
try something like that you can easily
trade and just play Queen to C3 you
never have to worry about this diagonal
so instead Pawn to A4 and now Ponte A5
not allowing B4 as you guys know how
potent B4 can be in any position uh we
have Queen to D2
uh and now B6 uh the an extra layer of
defense for that A5 Pawn uh Rook to B1
now trying to get that b for moving but
just Queen to A3 we have King to H2 Fabi
gets his King to a bit of a safer Square
Ponte H6 and now Rook the B2 we have
Queen back to E7 and now Rook the seat
to Fabi offers a trade and nepo just
goes Rook to C5 he says all right we can
trade but we trade under my terms uh so
Knight to F3 and now Rook captures on C2
we play Bishop captures on C2 and now
just Queen to C5 so no worries there uh
nepo not very impressed with what um
Fabi has done and again the E3 Pawn
might be a little bit weak so Bishop to
D3 uh King to f8 and now Knight the D4
we have King back to G8 nipple says I
don't have a plan here if you have
something then you know show it to me
otherwise you know we can we can call it
a day uh King to G1 by Fabi with King to
f8 and now King death two nipple goes
King t7 win the B2 now again this might
be an issue so uh we have uh just came
back to f8 Nepal says Nope the G7 Pawn
will be nicely defended and Knight the
C2 now we have knighted the E4 with
check and uh here Fabi trades characters
captures and now Knights the D4
uh we have Bishop the C6 and now Queen
to E2 we have a queen to C3 and now we
have Queen to A6 by Fabi so going after
that Queen to C8 check uh so Queen to D2
with check Knights the E2 and now Queen
back to B for putting pressure on the B3
pawn and Fabi defends it by going back
Queen to C8 with check or rather you go
forward to go back with Bishop T8 and
now Queen all the way back to C2 to
defend the B3 Pawn with Bishop to D7 by
nepo Knights to D4 and now even Pawn to
F5 uh defending that E4 pawn queen to C7
attacking the bishop here and here uh a
nipple really had no troubles um uh you
know just uh guarding his King defending
the position but here what do you
actually play the bishop is attacked you
can't really move the bishop player
let's say you play a weird move like
Bishop p8 you get checkmated right away
I mean what is this a king the Jade
Queen captures and G7 will be Checkmate
there's no way to do anything about this
so here we have Queen to D2 with check
Knight back to E2 and now Bishop to E6
this is on Apple defends but now the
problem is you hang your B6 Pawn but
okay he has a ways of winning it back
perhaps Queen captures some B6 King to
F7 and now Queen to D4 now Fabi wants to
quickly trade Queens he just won a pawn
nepo declines goes after the B3 Pawn but
Fabi trixom Queen to A7 with check King
to G8 and now Queen to A8 with check
King to H7 and queen captures an A5 now
Fabi is up two pawns but it seems um
nipple can just win back the pawn and
then being up one Pawn will not really
be all that impressive and the problem
is you don't have a good way of of
taking this if you play Bishop captures
then you hang the F5 Pawn with check of
course you you can't play that and if
you play Queen captures uh it's a much
trickier but let's say Knight D4 attacks
the queen and the bishop you move the
queen with check King G3 and you move
the bishop uh but still Knight Will
gobble up the pawn and now it doesn't
matter what you do queen captures an A4
you can trade Bishop captures but now
the pawn will fall and you're just gonna
be up two pawns so now you're up a pawn
let's say you go Knight to the D4
doesn't really matter what black plays
if you play G6 F5 is coming you have to
clear that F4 Square for the white king
and if G captures You're Gonna Play
Knight captures and very quickly gobble
up that pawn and even if you don't even
you can just play King to F or you're
not not in rush to to recapital it's a
bishop D7 now you capture and once the
king moves of course you're gonna play
something like Knight to G3 win the pawn
be up two pawns and when you're up two
Pawns of course you are completely
winning so that's why after Queen
captures an A5 nepo cannot capture even
a single Pawn he has to try King Day
cheat and now Fabi plays Queen 38 with
Chuck King the H7 and now Queen back to
A5 nipple says all right King date I'm
very happy with the draw but Fabi says
not so fast Pawn to B4
and even though Nepal was able to
prevent Ponte B4 for some 55 moves now
it happens with Bishop to C4 uh Fabi
might have been a little reluctant at
first uh playing this B4 move as it
frees up the C4 Square for Nepal's
Bishop but this is how Fabi plays it
Queen 38 with check King to H7 and now
Queen to D1 guarding A4 and also the
Knight on E2 so this queen uh
possibility of checking the the black
king just uh going back to defend the
white pieces uh is uh I mean they're
working perfectly for Fabi this game
with Bishop to B3 now and you could also
win the pawn but it doesn't mean
anything let's say Bishop captures
You're Gonna Play Queen captures and now
Queen captures an A4 uh Queen C4 the
pawn marches forward and you have no way
of stopping this so after a queen to D1
Bishop to B3 attacking the pawn and the
queen but just Queen to D7 now Fabi says
I'm gonna grab the F5 pawn and now we
have Bishop to A6 and now Queen to B5
again everything is nicely defended uh
King to h8 and now Queen to C5 just
making room all right to start pushing
that that pawn and it seems like you're
giving up the the A4 Pawn but if Queen
captures an A4 then Knights the D4 and
then uh you will again lose the F5 Pawn
you have to worry about all sorts of
checks that you are uh yeah you are
losing this very quickly so here we have
Pawn to G6 nipple has to waste the move
to guard the F5 Pawn with something
other than his bishop and now King to E1
we have King to G8 it now comes Queen to
D6 uh puts pressure on the bishop so of
course again you cannot capture an A4
King the F7 now defends the bishop and
now we have Queen to D2 just offering a
queen trade and Fabi had to make a move
very quickly here because he uh only had
like a minute on the clock no 48 minutes
on the clock uh and um of course here
you don't have time controls to gain
additional time you do have increment
but you know you still uh have to make a
move every move and the problem is here
if you just start advancing your Pawn
then Queen B1 check and you probably
have a Perpetual King to F2 Queen comes
to C2 and now with the bishop coming to
C4 there's no way for the White Queen to
stop all this Queen Bishop action so
here instead the queen to D2 was played
by Fabi this stops this idea now Queen
captures an A4 Fabi gives up one pawn
and now Knights the D4 so uh you know
shifting one type of Advantage into into
another one uh with Bishop to C4 and now
King to F2 we have Pawn to H5 uh just
King to G3 not a problem with Queen to
A3 uh as the E3 Pawn might be a little
bit weak here so now you're saying okay
your queen is stuck here guarding the E3
Pawn guarding the B4 Pawn but just Pawn
to B5 Fabi doesn't care and uh how do
you how do you play this it seems maybe
uh you you could some how capture that
pawn but not really here Queen to D3 was
played uh nipple tried uh either trading
queens or or maybe even just you know
getting the Queen off of the defense of
the E3 Pawn or maybe even just winning
the B5 Pawn but the position is now
completely winning for Fabi but only if
he finds one very specific idea uh so
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for Fabi uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on beating Yan
nipomishi for the first time in your
life and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Queen to C1 it's
a really odd looking move that wins the
game but what you're gonna do if it wins
it wins the problem is uh how do you how
do you play this there's no good way if
you were wondering about Queen captures
on D3 just e captures and the pawn is
now uh sufficient the D Pawn is not
sufficient to to gain a draw but after
Queen to C1 how do you play this bishop
capture some B5 has to be played
otherwise B6 is coming so nepo captured
it but now Queen to C7 with check and
now you will see if you had your dots
about the queen Knight combo now you
will see what the queen Knight combo
does and a nipple is without a move if
the King goes look at this if the King
goes to G8 then look at this beauty
queen today with check King to G7 now
Knight to E6 with check whatever play
doesn't really matter you're getting
checkmated King F7 Knights the G5 check
King to G7 Queen to E7 with check and
now it whatever you play like the king
to G8 You're Gonna Play Queen to F7 with
the check or H7 followed by F7 or F7
followed by h8 and queen to H7 with
Checkmate so that's one way to do it
nipple decided to try and avoid this he
played the king to f8 right away but now
Fabi just played Queen to C5 with the
check and he was in this position on
move 70 that Yani publisher resigned to
the game and a beautiful beautiful
victory for Fabiana corvana who takes
down the former World Chase Championship
Challenger and also beats Nepal for the
first time in his life in a classical
game so absolutely spectacular the
problem is um uh whatever you play
wherever the the black king goes you can
just capture the bishop here and then
the E3 Pawn will defend it so leaving
black with zero chances of maybe getting
getting some sort of a Perpetual or if
you go to EA then you can even just
trade Queens like the queen captures
with check you capture Europa full night
and doesn't even matter if you play
something else you play King t7 you can
even trade captures captures the king
easily stops the pawn so it's not not
even close uh so after Queen the C5
check uh Nepal resides and Fabi wins
another game so that's second game in a
row that Fabi wins in classical previous
game he defeated Maxine barcela Graf
check it out if you haven't I've covered
the game and here sorry not that that's
uh something else I wanted to show you
guys the standings um
which I'm pretty sure I had
um and I have prepared them all right
just give me a second I'm just gonna
check real quickly for some reason I
don't have them
I don't want to trick you guys
yeah I know I saved them here there we
go
all right so here are the standings of
the
uh super bet chess classic round four uh
after four rounds you can see that Fabi
is now in Seoul lead with three points
uh so not a very nice Lamb by Fabi
followed by two points uh
dingler and a niche Gear with two points
Maxime and Yanks used to do that with a
point in half and in last place uh
Bogdan Daniel Dak so I will see what
happens can Fabi continue this Exquisite
run and it's a tough loss for nepo
because not only uh does he lose a
classical game after after losing that
world's championship match to the
England but also uh he was extremely
close to uh you know hitting that uh
2800 uh now I realized that I might have
um misspelled Naples rating yeah of
course I have for some reason uh I had
it right the first time but I just uh
miswrote it for some reason
there we go at least at least uh we're
gonna finish it nicely for the for the
rest of the video because Nepal is very
very close to 2800 so I don't wanna
butcher it like this but yeah as you can
see it's 27.94 and uh yeah he was very
close but still If he if he wins a
couple of games uh you know the
tournament is still happening maybe he
hits that 2800 Mark he's the closest one
uh to achieving this at this moment uh
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank Edwin Freeman
Evan bursting uh ravishing reptiles
YouTube a Lord of Bones in Mazi and
elsaac for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful classical event uh until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and once again big congratulations
at the Fabi for his first winning
classical against the animation see you
soon